Peter King back here on the show how are
you Peter hey rich how you doing how
would you answer that poll question most
dangerous player in the league
well I would say Patrick mahomes right
now
but I think that anybody who says Khalil
Mack or Aaron Donald has a good argument
just that if you touch the ball on every
single offensive snap I think it just
allows you to be more dangerous and
certainly significantly more productive
than any defensive player can be in a
game well you know it's interesting
we're in obviously an overreaction
business or a reaction business in the
NFL more than any other sport and it
seems that the reaction in December is
the one that's most serious because it's
the one that could be the most
indicative of of a team's chances that
said Nick Foles kind of blew that one
out last year and here he comes again on
Sunday night Peter and that was your
lead item of your column what what did
you make of the Nick Foles performance
and the viability for the Eagles right
now well I mean it's probably too late
for the Eagles but they've got a chance
obviously they need to count on teams
above them losing virtually impossible
that they'll win the division with
Dallas having Tampa and the Giants
remaining and needing to lose both but I
think I think overall rich Nick Foles is
just one of those guys that's very hard
in a I don't know in a scouting sense or
in a in an analytic sense to basically
say yeah we don't love this guy he's
okay but you just want him on your team
he's just one of those guys it reminds
me when when I covered the Giants in the
80s they had a defensive end named
George Martin and Bill Parcells used to
say the ball just finds him and he would
make some incredible defensive plays
even though he might only play 20 snaps
a game and he'd make two or three plays
every game he was always around the ball
he was so instinctive and I almost feel
like that with foals
that you know put him in the game he
might not play great but usually when
you put him in a game your team is going
to do pretty well that's what you've
seen over the last say 53 weeks on the
calendar with Nick trolls and I I don't
doubt at all he's going to play well
against Houston this week and they've
got a good chance to win that game you
know and then they just need Minnesota
to lose once that's basically what they
need to have happen here Minnesota is at
Detroit and then home for Chicago which
has an opportunity potentially to get B
up to whether what Chicago has to play
for I think not that not that
Chicago is gonna lay down because I
don't think they would but how much will
they have to play for in that game and
if it's only the difference between
possibly the third and fourth seed you
wonder whether in that particular case
let's say Eddie Jackson is banged up and
they want to save they want to make sure
he's fully healthy for the playoffs
that's the kind of game where you can
you know conserve some of the guys who
you need to get healthy so it's you know
it it's easy to sit here and say well
Minnesota is gonna lose one of those
games but I don't know that they are
let's see well I mean who have to play
for what then well it could be one of
those things Peter where they put
Minnesota versus Chicago in a late
window on week 17 the same time that the
Rams play the 49ers to make sure that
it's entirely possible for the Bears to
get that two seed and then suddenly
they're out there and that might be the
way how Philadelphia to get into this
dance and so let me take this one by one
here Nick Foles performs as well as he
did on Sunday night and let's say he
continues to do that how does that put
what does that put in the mind's eye of
Philadelphia in this off season between
foals and Wentz is there really
something there there potentially I
think the only the only
the only way that that really matters
rich is if the doctors of the
Philadelphia Eagles say to Geoff Larry
Howie Rosamond Doug Peterson if they say
don't hey listen we got some real
questions long-term about Carson Wentz's
back or he's got some chronic knee
condition and I look I'm I don't think
either of those are the case but I'm
saying that the only way that I would
change my plan if I were the
Philadelphia Eagles is if my doctors
told me we're not sure that Carson Wentz
can stay healthy and or that Carson
Wentz might have a chronic back issues
or something like that otherwise Richard
can't pay two quarterbacks and at the
end of this year somebody is probably
going to pay I don't know who it's going
to be but let's say Tampa you know gets
rid of Jameis Winston or or manoj axon
ville obviously is going to be looking
for a quarterback miami might be looking
for a quarterback and what about the
giants and so you look at all these
things and there are other teams too you
look at that and I can't imagine that
the Eagles would pay Nick Foles enough
for him to turn down the opportunity one
more time in his life at least to have a
team and to be the starting quarterback
yeah that's why I love this time of year
Peter King is because not only is it
rubber meeting the road in terms of
playoffs but we're already looking over
the steering wheel for teams that aren't
you know on the outside looking in that
might not make it or teams that are
already done in futures and I want to
put a pin in that quarterback
conversation for the moment while we
turn to the here and now with Jared golf
I just seeing him he just does not
appear to be he's definitely not the
same quarterback that that that did what
what what he did against the Chiefs on
that Monday night game they struggled in
Detroit but one it looked like people
are already saying that the Bears broke
the Rams based on what we're seeing what
what do you look what do you see when
you watch golf play football right now
Peter
I see a guy who either to be kind
he's lost his mojo to be real he looks
totally shaken up out there he looks he
looks like I don't I don't know if
nervous is the right thing because I
don't know that it's nerves but rich you
can't do what this quarterback did
against Minnesota and lay deep throws
into a postage stamp of a window you
can't see that and now look at what
you're seeing and say that a golf will
be fine and that's why rich and rich
listen I stay up many times after the
Sunday night game and after the Monday
night game to watch NFL Network because
I want to see the press conferences I
want to see what these guys are saying
and you got to go back and look at Sean
McVeigh after this game because he for
the first time in the two years that
he's been the coach of this team he he
has he had I would say more than a
worried look in his eye and sounded
worried about his team he's always been
this guy rich you see him every single
week he's cocky is the wrong word he's
just intensely confident of what they're
doing and it keeps working if you don't
have a quarterback that you can trust
his offense can't work period that's all
there is to it so I think this is a
crucial we everybody said well you know
what's what team is in the most trouble
and obviously you can look at a bunch of
teams the Patriots don't look good and
all that I get it but the Rams from
where they were a month ago to today
that worried the crap out of me if I was
Sean McVeigh Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show which is more likely do you
think that the Chiefs don't get the 1
seed Chargers do or the Bears get the 2
seed and the Rams don't what do you
think more likely that the Chiefs get
the 1 seed I mean look their biggest
challenge is going to be going to
Seattle
going into the Temple of Doom there on a
very very loud night and the challenge
is going to be for them to find a way to
score enough to win that game and that's
that's the season right there because
you know if they win that game they're
going to get the number one seed and the
Chargers don't have it easy obviously
with the Ravens coming in and the Ravens
with this weird weird offense running
the ball 65% of the time or whatever it
is it's unbelievable in modern football
in winning I mean this in so many ways
rich has been the coolest season because
a month ago we said well that's it
nobody's playing defense anymore and
then get a team that changes
quarterbacks and they start running far
more than they're passing and then you
start having 12 to 9 games with the same
it's totally totally fascinating and I
just think it goes to show that that
that's why people love the NFL so much
who would have thought that Drew Brees
would struggle mightily to score 12
points against a 6 and 16 I wouldn't
have or whatever they were coming into
that gloom Peter King here and the Rich
Eisen showing yeah I'm gonna give voice
to that and my 4 down segment next hour
that's the most wide-open season I've
seen in a long time Peter I mean there
you could really say 1012 teams have a
shot at winning the Superbowl if they
catch fire right now it really is
totally well the reason the reason open
say that rich is because the Patriots
are mortal and usually at this time of
year we're all saying yeah well you know
the Patriots are coming and so there's
one spot in the Superbowl but I don't
think anybody can look at them right now
and think with confidence that they're
gonna make it now I will say one thing
about the Patriots that that you know
I've read and I've heard and everything
that Brady has done it's all Brady
everything like that
I'll tell you what it is it's the fact
that in their you know in a game they I
wouldn't say they had to have but they
needed in Pittsburgh Rob Gronkowski and
Josh Gordon who have been trending to be
the two most important targets for Brady
catch three
balls for 40 yards that's that's utterly
pathetic
quite honestly so they got to get Josh
Gordon involved consistently in this
offense because I do not trust Rob
Gronkowski to beat a big factor anymore
okay what how do you see the Green Bay
head coaching gig and Cleveland gigs
right now playing out because those are
the two coaching is you know it seems
like those are the two most two two best
jobs out there you know unless almost
Baltimore for some reason decides to do
what's rumored regard which would shock
me putting John Harbaugh yeah it would
surprise me it wouldn't shock me it
would surprise me though and you know
that's one of the reasons why you can't
really well who do you thinks gonna get
to Cleveland job do you thinks gonna get
this job if Harbaugh is out there I
could see a bidding war for a premier
coach and and I don't know exactly what
that would entail but I could see easily
I could see a couple of teams going nuts
trying to get hard well I certainly
would um the one the one thing I would
say about these jobs is that look Hugh
Jackson in two and a half years won
three games in the last six weeks
the Browns at 1/4 so the landscape has
changed and the one thing and I do not
mean to dis Greg Williams in any way
shape or form
I don't but to me the biggest thing
that's happened in Cleveland is that
Freddie kitchens the new offensive
coordinator has thrown Baker Mayfield in
that offense a lifeline and when I look
at that team right now I want to watch
every play of the Browns me too they're
the most compelling team in the NFL
right now I love it I want to I
seriously I turn him on every week
almost at the exclusion of everybody
else I'm totally fascinated with what's
going on they couldn't walk and chew gum
for the last five years and now look at
him so I think I think Cleveland this is
insane I think
the best job out there and it's so
insane to say that with Aaron Rodgers
having four or five years left how in
the world couldn't you want that job
over Cleveland the only reason is at
least in my opinion is I'll take Baker
Mayfield for the next 12 years over
Aaron Rodgers for five Peter King here
on the Rich Eisen show let's revisit
what we put a pin in which is the
quarterback market you know you
mentioned foals
obviously it looks like Flacco is going
to be out there as well and then just
the odd marriage between quarterbacks
and teams you look at the team's
drafting in the top ten right now not
many really need a quarterback like
desperately need a quarterback with the
exception of remarkably the Jaguars so
you know my question is is how many
teams you think are gonna be in the
market for quarterbacks and and and and
a name that you think would be on the
market for a free agency that you don't
expect
well I I think you asked a very
interesting question about the Jaguars
because I don't I think when you talk
about coaches who could be in trouble
I don't know why Doug Marrone wouldn't
be on that list he's supposed to be the
second coming of Tom Coughlin mr.
discipline that has been one of the
loosest ships if not the losses ship in
the NFL this year and you know the head
coach is responsible for that he's
responsible for not being able to
control Jalen Ramsey and and again in
the offseason when he says what he says
the GQ that's fine but but can't
somebody in that organization which is
supposedly this-this-this disciplined
organization can't somebody in there say
shut up you idiot okay can anybody say
that and can it work it just seems it
just seems like the Jaguars III would I
would seriously consider whether you
know Marone is the guy to lead that team
for work that's just my thought as far
as the interesting players out there I
think the one interesting quarterback
who will fascinate teams is Teddy
Bridgewater and I know that Ron Payton
likes him a lot and I know that he'll
he'd have a significant amount of
interest out there in part because I
think people will look at him and say
you know here's one guy I don't have to
pay 27 million dollars to that's just
that sort of the way I think that in my
opinion I look at Bridgewater and he's a
fascinating player but he's still
unproven and so I think he'd be the one
x-factor on the market I mean if you had
your choice right now rich tell me
Harvey to rather have it Sam rather have
Teddy Bridgewater Nick Foles I'd have
him in a heartbeat and I was talking to
the other day Peter that if the Giants
want to move on from Eli Manning this is
the guy to do it and and and yeah
because you him in the backfield would
say Kwan for years to come and throwing
- Odell would make the Giants just as
fascinating in my mind as the Browns and
yeah and I'd love to see that stuff the
point I would make it I would think the
money you'd have to pay on the market
right now you'd have to pay
significantly more for Falls because of
the Super Bowl thing and because every
time he comes in he seems to get the job
done no matter how he looks so I think I
just think the quarterback market is
really going to be interesting this
offseason Peter one last one for you the
college coach named that you're hearing
is a real truly viable hire but would
really think of coming and that a league
the league team would either throw a ton
of money to make sure he comes or would
be just intrigued in I have not heard of
a soul out there I would think that
Lincoln Reilly but I have I've not heard
of a soul out there who really wants to
come at least as of right now and if
Lincoln Reilly is going to be that guy
he would have a lot of interest in the
NFL I think David Shaw these are not the
two jobs even though I mean if I hey
listen if I were either John Dorsey or
Mark Murphy Brian gudykunst in Green Bay
I would make David Shaw say no to me
because he is a fascinating fascinating
guy who knows the NFL exceedingly well
and I would make him say no to me but if
you're asking me who does the NFL who's
the NFL pretty sure is going to come
from college to pro if you ask them I I
don't I don't know of a guy there's not
an obvious guy this year Peter thanks to
the time as always have a great holiday
season if we don't talk before hey
thanks very much rich preciate you
brought you bet that's Peter King the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience